tis the season for new trailers I says
that's as much singing as you're getting
out of me my name is anthony wayne I'm
joined tonight by Ryan Daley and we're
going to talk about the some of the
flood of trailers that came out in the
last week week and a half or so I said I
suppose we'll start with the elephant
the room the sort of the big 10 was
spider-man homecoming hmm my
appreciation for the spider-man trailer
has grown a little bit more over time
the first time I watched it I wasn't
disappointed I wasn't let down there was
nothing about that like jumped out like
a red flag and maybe say I don't like
that or I don't care for that or there
was nothing like that but my first
reaction was just slightly underwhelmed
and the reason for that was to me and
they use the tone it was a mix of the
music it was a mix of like the jokes
with him still being young but it felt a
lot like okay this could just be the
next step in the amazing spider-man
trilogy it's like okay it feels of a
piece it doesn't feel like an entire new
evolution of this character which does
not bad it still feels like spider-man
and that was my initial thing so I was
like okay it looks fun I'm sure I'll
like it but it didn't wow me over time
slightly I've just kind of like okay I
like that a little bit more I like this
a little bit more its kind of notched
itself up so i obviously i did my live
reaction to it as a separate video check
it out if you haven't already um I liked
I liked a lot of it i really like Tom
Holland I lunch it'll fit I love his
energy and I love sort of the the way
he's able to balance the sort of fast
talking but also awkward and kind of
weird thing and there were moments that
are written like in the instant that I
saw it I loved that image of him holding
together the Staten Island Ferry yeah
although almost immediately I had this
thought they're trying really hard to
one-up the stopping the train from
spider-man to what we could see of the
action
really good I I did like that scene at
the end it's always nice to remind
people that spider-man is really really
strong and he's often put in place word
when he has to demonstrate his strength
it's usually that type of thing it's not
him going toe-to-toe with the Hulk or
four it's him he can't write it's it's a
classic image of him holding up
something incredibly heavy to buy people
time to get out of the building and
that's you know that that's a great sort
of natural character and heroic be for
that beat for the character they're
really they were promoting tony stark
and robert downey jr's involvement in
that's my which nobody could fault them
for doing that no I don't I don't think
he will have a huge part in the world I
don't I don't think he will either but I
didn't love that we saw him in the Iron
Man suit now first of all I'm iffy about
that being in the movie at all because
just let spider-man be spider-man um and
don't have somebody else muscling in on
it but beyond that it's that thing that
it keeps happening over and over and try
while I would not is probably not a plot
spoiler right that iron man flies in the
suit that's something I would rather
have been surprised by right going into
the theater and now I can't be villains
of the movie um well yeah so we got well
we got vulture can we had a little bit
of Michael Keaton and he sounds like
he's now got the gruff they gandhi's
channeling Birdman I like that we are
seeing him take on guys robbing ATMs I
mean that in my mind especially at this
point that is what Spidey should be
doing right that is the exact sort of
thing he needs to be dealing with and I
think the vulture is a good escalation
of that because we didn't get this so
much from the trailer but what the
director has basically said is the
vulture is not some grand schemer he's
just a career criminal who's going well
the crime fighters are stepping up their
game yeah I'm gonna step up my game and
I think that's that is a proper
escalation that still keeps it and
within the realm that makes sense for
Spidey to be dealing with on his own
right and we see some of that I think
being filtered out through one of the
characters that they say and I don't
know if we saw him in the trailer
in route actually I don't know who's
playing him but supposedly the tinkerer
uh yeah but he's doing who's just do
just makes me like I think he's just
going to be sort of a non-combatant evil
Tony Stark he's just going to be like a
weapons during rigor like just like
farming out these weapons gotta kind of
be responsible for getting some of these
weapons suits in a way that gets us away
from Oscorp for once as Donald Glover's
character been named no because the one
shot he's in which does he's highlight
him plus standing next to obviously a
villain and a henchman who's gearing up
to use some tech right an azide whether
if the G the guy who looks like Tom
Hardy but isn't Tom Hardy the guy forget
me this he's just hang out but he's
obviously like just there hanging with
what is obviously a solid guy if you
could be the Tinker I think that would
be kind of cool that I mean that's what
I was just thinking it hadn't occurred
to me until just now but I go with that
right I'm not gonna say it makes me like
pumped like year but like you said
there's no red flags right I think one
of the things that they needed to depart
from the amazing spider-man was the love
story melodrama and that is a part the
soap opera aspect is a part of
spider-man's universe it always has been
but I think they went overboard with
this they do the last problem and I
think we need to see him not in love
with a girl well and maybe that would
maybe he'll be with Liz maybe you'll be
with somebody else but that just wasn't
what we saw in this trailer if they're
going to step back on the romantic drama
but they still want to have the soap
opera aspects keeping him in high school
is a good way to do that because high
school is a it's just a boiling pot of
drama that does not need to be romantic
drama and you can still have those so
poverty aspects without having him
pining for whoever well we'll wrap up
Marvel and we'll go guardians the galaxy
two this is the property of marvel that
has the weirdest kind of effect on me
and then because they just like they
were the characters that I didn't really
like that much um and after I saw the
movie I've wasn't I didn't want to go
back and read their comics there was
nothing
I didn't have that nostalgic kick and
when I ranked by movies it falls
somewhere in the middle but i can
tonight it's a really really fun movie
and when I watch it I'm like smiling
almost the entire time and then after
it's over I kind of forget those things
but so this was one where i was i gather
doing a sequel i knew they were going to
do a sequel I wasn't really excited and
like yeah of course I'm going to see it
it's gonna be good because they've got a
winning formula and I watch this thing I
like oh man this isn't good this looks
really really fun why am I excited for
this but yeah I just I can't it's just
weird that it has this effect so like
everything from the music the the sweet
song that they've got in there is this
trailer is heavy on grew in the rocket
well I think because I have a feeling
that they probably isolated that scene
that they use like this is going to be a
good trailer sleep let's get this
wrapped and locked so that we can use it
as people love Groot and Rocket right
and now baby group would they be grouped
going to sell all the everything all
those guys in the world is going to be
baby grew the mixing though at the end
when we get a new character mantis um
the woman who is an established
character in guardians League and in the
Avenger she's a former Avenger so I
really hope they do a lot with this
character she seems to have this sort of
empathic she touches him said you feel
love sexual love for her drastic
reactions is that I love that I was like
that is better than anything that did it
the first one it work it reminds you why
you had fun the first time you know yeah
I gotta be sure to catch that yeah oh
there was the mummy hmm with Tom Cruise
the mummy featured pretty lightly yeah
in the trailer itself I was surprised
how many things that i'm watching this
and going that's really clever so like
specific examples a lot of what was
going on in that plane sequence mm-hmm
that looked really well staged the two
iris i think i'm watching the eyes just
split and like it's really cool so i am
a big fan of the classic Universal
strip characters and when I heard that
Universal was going to try again Jim res
I mean they they had false start with
the Medici Oh del Toro Wolfman movie
which was awful than the last Dracula
aguila untold until was what I I didn't
see it i just remembered the trailer
where he bat punches in turkish army
they're trying again and they're really
committed ok we're going to do this
whole shared universe Marvel style DC
style cos hey that's what the kids are
into I understood that I applaud that
I'm actually cool do that do a horror
type of thing so I wanted to get a scary
mummy movie and that is not what I got
from this train know if you wanted scary
this is not selling you scared this
looks like another Jack Reacher Mission
Impossible movie now it looks good like
the action thing like and everything
like you said wick with the opening like
flat plain sequence like I reminded me I
was like okay mission impossible 5 open
with him of like stuck to the side of
that airplane does it this feels like a
logical segue to the head is like the
next scene this looks like it could be a
really really cool Tom Cruise action
movie but I don't know if it's the mummy
movie that I want and also just looking
at the mummy Shin which cool she looks
different or she would look different if
not for the Enchantress from the Suicide
Squad movie I'm not sure the stink of
that's gonna be hanging too heavily
because I think most people want to
forget the attack it was in my mind was
the first thing that I thought of when I
saw her and actually been denied occur
to me and I'm one of the ones i look at
Danny enchantress didn't even wasn't
supposed to look like it I like the
classic mummy and the wraps and
everything I have no particular
attachment to the classic black and
white mummy I do have a it's not good
but I enjoy it attachment to the 1999
the mummy with brendan fraser and
actually even the first sequel I
honestly not ironically enjoy those
there's a fair chunk of the audience
that if they know the mummy at all they
know it more as an action franchise then
they know it is a horror franchise one
of the other things that sort of already
kind of bummed me out about this planned
shared universe is the next movie in
this series is going to be the
double man starring Johnny Depp he's
kind of tainted for me I don't want to
see him in one of these movies right now
I'm just but you won't see him cuz it
invisible okay good Yeah right into that
one I think each individual one there's
the potential for me to find some
interest in but in terms of a universe I
just I don't care sure speaking of
things I don't care about trailer for
transformers 5 or first night last night
last night as our friend and occasional
councilmember pulse comido calls it
transformers I know what you did last
night um so it looks like the last
couple Transformers movies it looks like
every other transformers movie like
theirs they keep trying like every death
in football I suppose first of all first
discloses the only one I've seen all the
way through is the first one I have no
intention of sinking the time to ever
watch any of the rest of them all the
way through until one comes out that
people are going to the rest were bad
but this one is actually good until
that's the universal consensus I'm not
sitting down to watch another one of
these I'm just not doing it the first
one I can still defend a little bit not
going to break my back doing it but i
will say the first one had a certain
degree of charm and I could see Steven
Spielberg's fingerprints on it and so
yeah apparently Optimus Prime was dead
or dies in this one and then comes back
and might be they get clean up too high
if they were gonna grab your attention
regarding Optimus Prime they played that
hand twice in the course of a two minute
trailer once by showing what looks like
his body dead floating in space like
okay but then again showing him tearing
through Autobots and say I'm sorry as
he's about to stab bumblebee is like
okay you Jason just tried to catch the
same check twice which is it and Kevin
this is me really giving them
now maybe in the movie it'll make sense
I also realized something watch in the
trailer it doesn't you can't reconcile
those two things no I realized something
while watching this and i am a openly
proud nerd I fan of this deep culture
stuff I still enjoy the coronal
transformers cartoons but I realized i
hearing Anthony Hopkins say the name
Optimus Prime it's not something I ever
needed or wanted to hear I'm not gonna
say yeah I'm not gonna see it either and
I just I mean for my part I've never
really cared about transfer I had one I
never watched the show I had one
transformers toy growing up that I
didn't play with often cuz it would I
don't remember the character but it was
a fire engine and he didn't transform a
him was a big pain in the ass and it was
almost never worth it to me so that's
that's my overall feeling about
transformers of the franchise it not
worth the bother come at me in the
comments most nice war for the Planet of
the Apes thank you this for me is kind
of a big one because this franchise has
quietly under the radar become one of my
favorite franchises of the last five
years but it looks great and you know
any circuses voice is the first thing we
hear which is what I love Caesar as a
character he is wonderful I like the
tone I actually I don't know if I had
known ahead of time if i had i forgot
buddy Harrelson was in this so when he
showed up shaving his head I was like oh
crap I'm slightly worried that the vibe
on this trailer seems like the lines are
finally being drawn as good guys bad
guys because I think about the other
films and there may have been specific
individuals who were bad guys but there
wasn't you couldn't draw a line in the
sand up the humans are good the apes are
bad so the solve that I'm putting on
that concern is there probably
oversimplifying for the sake of the
trailer very well could be but also just
looking at the state of things I mean
Gary Oldman's character they were
survivalists yes his decision
and when they presented him as a villain
it was based out of fear and the sort of
self-preservation what he would he
thought he was doing the best for these
things are human characters which are
presented as our ver this FML is ever
military there they look like the evil
army that's like and that this is just a
war situation and on the war you got the
good guys in the bad guys but it looks
good I the signature moment that I just
remember from the trailer is an a it
looks like Caesar although if this might
sound a little bit species us but all
day just look the same to me Thank know
what is it is maybe I've gotta have to
cut that alia awful I know gonna get so
much hate mail um Harambee much love um
but there is a there's a shot where it
looks like Caesar is on his knees with a
gun to his temple and does this kind of
looks I love beans can do it like oh
you're gonna shoot me do it that is like
daring them to [ __ ] that that is
definitely Caesar that but oh that's a
good image like that world mmm yeah okay
I'm in um I'm gonna see this one opening
night we got new trailer for Assassin's
Creed not being a gamer I've never
played the game I don't have an
investment in this I like Michael
Fassbender I like what is her name
marion cotillard yeah pitcher and you
pronounce it better than i would've so
um I like the people involved in this
visually it looks cool but i know most
video games adapted to films in fact i
think you would point out that no video
game adapted to film has really
succeeded yet has not and i believe will
not and based on this trailer i'm
officially calling it this movie's gonna
suck okay um your reasons sir well my
reasons I think what ultimately killed
it for me was they they did something
that to me says they don't know what
they're doing um which is that and I
forget what the names were now because
it went out of my head but like they
were be sure they like put emphasis on
first and last name for Michael
Fassbender's character first last name
for marion cotillard character as if
those things are important they're not
the fact that they
these emphasis on these days like they
mean something to help me jack so
they're not tapping into a fan base oh
they're getting there so I don't
understand why you would do that when
why you put all this emphasis on these
names when these names have no meaning
these are characters that are new to the
the story to the franchise so between
that and I'm watching the rest and this
was the one where they really seemed to
try and break down the story like trying
to have it make sense first of all it
still barely makes sense the thing is it
barely makes sense in the games but the
games get away with it because you get
the visceral thrill of getting to do so
much cool stuff then is Ubisoft which is
the game developer they that this movie
was supposed to happen much sooner than
it did okay the reason it didn't was the
amount of control Ubisoft was demanding
they be able to maintain over the film
what's going on as far as I'm sorry it
cannot be blamed on a studio that
doesn't get the property because you
basalt has his fingers to deepen this
pie okay so this is this is going to be
this to me see I every time a new video
game movie comes out and sucks it
becomes another debunking of another one
of the myths as to why it hasn't worked
up to this point with Warcraft being
painful um that was a debunking of the
well they just never got a good director
on it Duncan Jones is a good director
yeah he couldn't know didn't work and I
feel that this one is going to be a
debunking of the well it's just cuz they
get too far away from the games that
well no now you're going to have the
game developer right in there making
sure they're staying true to its still
gonna suck so I'm probably not going to
see it I'm looking forward to it tanking
so it will just it will justify my
continued stance that this is never
going to work um hi I'd uh it's where i
am i am starting to get a certain amount
of almost fetishistic glee out of this
and that's not normal for me normally I
don't do the schadenfreude
a thing with but with video game movies
I kind of get that a little bit because
I feel like out of geek speek gives
people I'm one of the only people I know
who's beating the drum up this will
never work as opposed to oh it will work
one day it'll maybe this one or that no
it's never gonna work so it's never
gonna work so i think i think we've
saved the big one for last yeah he said
this is this is the trailer that hit
thank you may wash bless you if there
was one movie I really wanted to see the
rock in all my life haha Bay watch I
didn't see the first 21 Jump Street
somehow I saw the second one mm-hmm a
buzz okay I kind of get it there's a few
parts where I almost sort of laughing it
wasn't for me but I kind of appreciate
it and watching this trailer and I admit
guilty pleasure I have seen more than a
few episodes of the old babe watch TV
I've only just seen the opening credits
and I kind of feel like that was as good
as it was going to get you're not wrong
I saw a lot more than that and you're
not wrong but I kind of it it's candy
most of the time it was self-aware and
knew why people were watching it and I
feel like this this trailer is doing it
a lot with that too and it's it's not
all the women I'm there's certainly more
than enough man candy fur oh yeah I
actually say in that trailer there's way
more actually yeah cuz in terms of the
stab my stuff honest that's already the
rock and zac efron are two pretty
high-profile end the highest-profile
female star movie is as alexandra
daddario i hate it i think her first
name is alexandra daddario is Alexander
she was in true detective she was also
in last year's rock movie the San
Andreas one I think we're Shauna's
daughter um beautiful woman gorgeous
going to look great in a bathing suit
well does if you if you watch the
trailer but she I think she's the the
female lead of this and not like a big
star but I mean it's yeah it's going to
be a lot of pretty people on the beach
pretending they can't swim very well
to be rescued it's Baywatch it you know
what you're getting there it shouldn't
have any illusions about it and it's not
selling itself as something that it
probably won't be so I'm fine with it
did you know it the chances of me seeing
that are astronomically higher than me
seeing transformers I know what you did
last night yes ya know ah ditto sup man
that that ain't nothing yeah um so I
guess we'll wrap it up there um I forgot
to let you plug stuff last time so oh
yeah um you can find me on a number of
podcasts that are available on the fire
and water podcast network the new one
that I'm very proud of is Batman
nightcast where me and Chris Franklin
talk about Batman comics from the 1980s
also hosts a show called midnight
podcasting our several other shows i
also am the writer of a webcomic called
my pet ninja which is available at
Rising Sun comics com and one of the co
writers and co-creators of red and green
another webcomic at Rising Sun comics
com I'm sorry I nodded off a it's just
white noise because you have so much
crap to plug well thank you for joining
me Ryan and thank you for tuning in if
you're watching this on youtube you can
check out the complete mostly unedited
version on the Council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher so in
any case thank you for joining us and
this council is adjourned